if you post it with me doing my boobs
everyone's like my name is Greg we're
gonna check out today from the channel
buzz pranks kissy prank would you kiss a
youtuber edition kissing games 2016 I
have failed many times at this are you
trying to do this yeah I've gone to
Venice Beach thank you
they have taken a cam be like hi I have
over 350 thousand subscribers can I get
a kiss and on the mouth yeah I know
whatever kiss me really no not one
mm-hmm bunch of [ __ ] out there
Wow one I'm Greg and I kiss in front of
my mom for a pilot doesn't for your mom
she was in the pilot your mom wasn't oh
yeah that was it and then you have to
kiss Pratt's any shape to like make out
with like a girl or something or you can
feel comfortable they kiss in front of
the camera yeah that's right get over
hers and you were just wow you also know
that I didn't kiss anyone for reals I
guess for guys and I kissed a lot more
than I have right just like 15 yeah no
am i included
no yeah we didn't make out we kissed
like the shortest I mean you have to
make out on my cheek at one point which
was pretty funny
what's up guys it's David Boies or
backyard again with
here at Santa Cruz yesterday I'll be
doing part two from have you ever kissed
a youtuber so stay tuned to see how many
girls that kiss love your eyes hi what's
your name Anna Cassidy what's that crazy
scene you don't know big so far I made
my what's the craziest thing you've done
was into a pool yes but not like I
haven't done anything that's like worthy
are you spontaneous yeah yeah
have you ever liked kissing you to be
reborn hi would you oh my god Dario
thank you I like yourself I like you
where you're wearing today
would you ever like kids at youtuber
guys they don't want to make that one
choice I ever kissed the youtuber have
you ever kissed a youtuber before do I
look good let's say we switch hats
anyways hey these martinis yes would you
ever like kissing youtuber no why not
Wow Wow thank you guys so much for
watching this video make sure to give me
a watch it right now it's so damn funny
and just make sure to subscribe turn
your notifications on so every time I
post a new video you're the first one to
see it gonna spring break vibe like
drunk people movie subs this guy have
920 okay so he's almost a male if I get
like 600,000 more subs it's gonna be
like a walk in the park to kiss girls on
the beach I think you need to do it when
people are drinking I don't think so I
mean I don't know if that was real or
not but either way he kissed a lot of
girls
good for him I'm not jealous I'm not
jealous at all you ever kissed a
youtuber oh yeah I guess I have
never again Wow okay so you wouldn't
part if this guy came out to you got
breezes we have made out some embraces
but I didn't know some of those girls
are pretty cute than he was able to get
you know why cuz there's a camera like I
always talking about this there's a
camera people will do things in fact
that's the problem I have when I'm at
the Venice Beach the basis of girls gone
wild
hmm I think I'll shove your kids look
like what no this is my camera
show me your tips the camera people will
do things in front of the camera I want
to do this exact prank do it with a
camera have a person a person without
feeling that way they're like oh it's an
actual show don't have an iPhone doing
this anyone could be like well they made
it look like it happened so fast I
wonder if there was like an actual build
I think a lot of it is that fast
really if you think about it for too
long you won't do it I would I would
take it to the next step but like would
you have sex with a youtuber and then we
have sex right there on Venice Beach
boardwalk in front of the many pretty
dirty blades on the ground
Venice Beach always sounds cold so you
get there it's kind of dirty bang on
camera and John or someone John's Jonah
oh god I can't handle it all the
rebrands so then John would be filming
it John would be filming it you would be
watching it
I'd be periscoping it I'd be watching it
be a periscope where I'd be there also
is like the boom you'd be there also
you'll be the camera does it sound like
these girls didn't even know who he was
no they definitely don't that simple
girls are just Fame hungry so if there's
a camera and if then you just ask the
big thing I should try this I mean I
think you should try it but I think I
would succeed
you would get some yeah I wonder if
anyone rejected it will never reject
lady collie cut yeah so I'm thinking oh
man dude looks like a pimp I bet you
kids like five five really set goals for
yourself make your dreams happen yeah
superstars battling it out your
intention setting your intentions into
the universe right so I'd spent ten
minutes a day imagining and then
visualizing this happening and then I
would attract this into my life nobody
have to ask girls they just keep coming
up to me probably
hey guys if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe today become a reject
it'll be worth my time and Ariana has a
life on the internet too oh yeah
facebook.com slash Ariana boster he's at
it I don't have any idea she's a fan
panel be still be in the description box
Instagram at Ariana bad ass hurry
ERI and your ass is looking good these
days yeah you got flex your buddy likes
it
do you want to see what it looks like a
flex your butt it goes in because thank
God